I am a very traditionally seen as a very small woman.
Like, even when I go to get, like,
merch at a concert and I'm like, oh,
can I get a T-shirt?
They immediately assume small, and I'm like,
I'm literally a large.
But here's the thing.
People see me as skinny.
I. This is like, I'm a skinny girl.
We get the. We get the bloat.
The skinny girl bloat is real.
It's not. It's.
There's a lot of smoking
mirrors and good posture to the skinny girl thing, okay?
There's lots of chubby skinny girls.
So please, please,
please, please.
I love, I love when my,
my curvier friends do their thing,
because it really does give me confidence, because I'm like,
oh, god, people think I'm skinny,
but if they only knew I'm not really skinny.
And because skinny doesn't mean beautiful, and fat doesn't mean ugly,
you know what I mean?
So I love when we just, like,
show our natural bodies,
cause, like,
the girls be natural in.
And I mean, natural girls be natural.
I love you.